one down will the two others follow upen
president Liz mcel resigning in disgrace
after she was unable to condemn
anti-Semitism raging on her campus
during a congressional hearing last week
and the Harvard Board of Governors
reportedly meeting behind closed doors
to determine if their president Claudine
gay should be the next to go remember
she insisted that we should consider the
context on when students call for the
genocide of Jews protesters swarming
Harvard's campus with billboard trucks
that call for her firing but she is
getting some support about 700 members
of Harvard's faculty urging the board to
spare claudine's career in the name of
quote resisting political pressures and
Saturday Night Live seems to think that
the real villain here is the
congresswoman who asked the question the
show going after Alis stonic in a sketch
making light of
her now I'm going to start screaming
questions at these women like I'm Billy
ikner anti-Semitism yay or nay I'm sorry
what yes or no is calling for the
genocide of Jews against the code of
conduct for Harvard well it depends on
the
context what that can't be your answer
you pen lady same question yes or no
well we are serious about stopping all
forms of hatred anti-Semitism
islamophobia the second one and keep in
mind if you don't say yes you're going
to make me look good am I winning this
hearing so imagine judge that they
actually do a dress rehearsal for
Saturday Night Live and they still went
with this but we found out just before
the show that Sicily strong was
initially going to be a part of the
sketch and she backed out saying she was
uncomfortable with it yeah she was
uncomfortable with it and I think it
really speaks to her Integrity because
she had actually um had actually gone
through the uh when they did it ahead of
time um but I think that the
identification of of uh a le stonic as
the as the antagonist here as opposed to
recognizing what is going on in the
universities just shows how clueless
Saturday Night Live was I mean this is
not funny they couldn't make it funny
Alise stonic is not funny the whole
issue is not funny and you know what
these presidents instead of cloaking
themselves in this free speech um you
know at the at the same time they are
willing to shut down conservative speech
and it's interesting at Harvard where uh
Claudine gay is still president
apparently there was a deanship held by
a black law professor who then joined
the legal team of Harvey Weinstein and
they threw him off the uh out of the
University they took away his his uh his
deanship because they didn't like what
he did and yet they can't say the
killing Jews and calling for genocide is
worth throwing off campus it's like they
don't know what the conduct or the
context is what is the context other
than calling for the death of Jews and
the fact that you've got Jewish students
on campus who are afraid and Kudos goes
to people like Bill lman and the rest of
them who are not going to tolerate it
because the president is not standing up
for this no one is standing up for the
rights of the Jewish students who are
being intimidated and threatened and you
know locking themselves at as far as
Cooper Union is going in a library so I
think more than anything what they've
got to do is they've got get rid of all
of them uh McGill is the first one and
by the way she's not totally gone she
still has her uh she's still on the
faculty so that's kind of like a a
smoking mirrors yeah I wanted to ask you
about that Jesse the fact that so at m
at Miguel the president resigns but it's
not like she resigns as now is looking
for work she just resigns and goes back
to being a tenur
professor yeah that's like bid saying
he's not going to run for reelection but
we're still stuck with him for the rest
of his
term I see this is about money you know
these universities raise so much money
and most of these places don't care how
woke it gets as long as you keep
bringing in the money but when you screw
up this badly it's going to affect your
ability to raise money so if I were
Harvard I'd be thankful for Elise stonic
who cares if you're going to let her
look good she gave you an opportunity to
take this woman out and you have to take
this woman out fast because she is a
joke I was always told Harvard people
were smart I was always told that school
was for the best and the brightest I
always aspired to send Jesse Jr to
Harvard no longer he will be going to
Dartmouth or Princeton you expect the
president of a school like this to be
able to say yes or no yelling killed the
jews' harassment she couldn't do it I
don't think she's that bright I don't
think the lawyers that briefed her are
that bright apparently questions like
that along with is the border secure and
what is a woman stumps Democrats they
can't answer the question and I was just
at Trinity College where I went to
school Greg it's a prestigious
University in Harford Connecticut that's
a no it's a it's a university and I just
got briefed on my president online
school
she's just let me
finish she's also the president she's
probably the same type of person as as
gay at Harvard well I just got an email
from her that they've created a task
force on campus climate and that's a
followup to the task force of Trinity's
action plan for racial Justice the
school's falling apart the dorms don't
look great they haven't built anything
new they've brought in all these
students who hate Trinity who graduate
aren't successful and then can't donate
to Trinity so they're running out of
money and then they shut down two of the
fraternities at the campus and they ban
drinking on campus and like the school
is sitting there falling apart I'm not
going to be the president of Trinity
someone's going to have to save Trinity
and it better be someone better than
Miss gay or any of these other people at
these ivies they lead normal people who
can raise money and can answer simple
questions Greg this is the New York
Times headline as Fury erupts over
campus anti-Semitism conservative sees
the moment of course that's what we
that's what conservatives do best we
seiz we pounce isn't that interesting
how they suddenly forget the context
yeah it's like when when when
conservatives do there's just no context
but when they do something really really
bad they use six Decades of
context uh just briefly on the SNL thing
we don't know why strong backed out it
could be because it wasn't mean enough
like she wanted it to go harder we don't
know that there's a lot of comedy in
that I mean when you have a group of
academics who label any speech like
violating pronoun usage as violence but
then when someone actually calls for
violence they can't call that's hilar
ilious I mean the the hypocrisy is gold
but SNL is just they can't do that
they're cowards a lot of a lot of people
are calling this the going after the
professors as a suppression of free
speech um that I don't agree with that
because the in the calling for genocide
is an
intimidation to suppress free speech so
you got to show those people the door
it's not s when somebody's calling for
you to die uh that's to scare you into
silence so that is not free speech
anymore and then when they said well you
know what we're not it's it it only
becomes a problem when it's acted upon
so you have to wait for the genocide to
actually start before you can go excuse
me there will be consequences that's how
you got Nazi Germany it's crazy but you
know the interesting thing is they never
said it wasn't Free Speech they said
what we're asking you is would the code
of conduct allow this on your University
who knows better than the college
presidents well that's what I wanted to
ask Harold because Jesse brought up the
the the law firm that I can't remember
the name of the law firm but Wilmer Hae
okay Wilmer hail so Wilmer Hae briefed
and prepared for the testimony all three
of the presidents right and what I can't
imagine is one that no lawyer at will
Wilmer ha said this might be a problem
this doesn't sound good but that none of
the presidents said I'm not going to say
that I don't even believe that and yet
they get through all imagine you've
prepped people you've prepped for
hearings you've prepped for clients and
that is just astounding to me that
nobody raised their hand and said this
is going to be a problem it's going to
be back the the the test of leadership
for someone in that position uh
president of any organization certainly
a school uh institution of Higher
Learning and I think Jesse made a point
you may have been making light of it but
I think you're being serious Harvard is
a metaphor in most of our country for
what higher education the best of higher
education should look like uh and it's
under assault hopefully they're able to
recover Penn is a great University as is
Harvard and hopefully we're able to
recover I'm a graduate of pen to to your
point Dana I don't know how if someone
asked you the question uh that this
congresswoman M congresswoman stonic ask
about genocide of Jewish people killing
anyone does that violate your code of
conduct if you didn't know it or not you
would say violates my own personal code
yeah and number two it violates the code
of conduct at our University right and
if someone quarrels with you judge says
well it it does depend on if they act on
it I'd rather answer that question after
the hearing as opposed to being in the
hearing looking as if I'm saying it's
okay to kill any kid now second or third
our University of president has to make
it safe for kids to learn to be
challenged to descent to be able to
accept descent to understand a different
point of view but to Greg's point you
can't make it where a kid feels unsafe
because he or she believes that the
person they're conversing with debating
or a professor actually believes that
they shouldn't be allowed to sit in the
room because their people or people look
like them should be killed or should be
extinguished or exterminated these to me
seem like really simple things my
nine-year-old daughter was curious as
she we talked as how this could not be
something that uh no person could
understand her her school teaches
kindness and respect how how do you not
teach the these are just basic
principles so as as sad as I am for this
episode to be happening because I'm
close to it I signed many of these
letters asking for uh answers from Miss
and even asking for her resignation um
it's a sad day for my school but it's
one that I hope we move on from uh and
that we learn from and that we grow from
because we have a great Tradition at pen
and I hope that we are able to get back
to it a lot of people are writing about
that saying that uh Mill is only the
beginning for example and that was that
commentary you had a you yeah I just
want to finish because uh you know
Harold you brought up your nine-year-old
daughter and that's the point I wanted
to make was that your nine-year-old
daughter could Define who you know yes
who I know uh she could Define a
atrocity she could Define what a woman
is but you have this weird Trend where
the most powerful adult women in the
country can neither def Define a woman
or genocide two of the most easily
definable uh things on the planet and
when you try to force them to Define it
they require context for chromosomes and
context for sexual atrocity they're
putting I your daughter is not stained
by ideology yet they are they've gone
through the brainwashing industrial
complex they're putting ideology over
female victims that that how does a
person go from innocence to excusing
rape and murder there's a machine in
Academia that they go through and spits
that out that's the scary part and I
think the best way to destroy that
machine is what Elise did ask direct
simple straightforward questions to
these people under growth and everybody
in the country can see they can't answer
and the amazing thing is she kept asking
it over and over it's like a witness on
the stand if they keep asking it over
and over maybe I'm not given the right
answer you know and they know what the
answer is so any excuse whether it's
Wilmer hail or it's the Constitution has
nothing to do with the moral core of
calling for the death of people indeed
all right up next President Biden
getting walloped in the polls and
panicking Democrats think Hillary
Clinton could save the day hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analyses you will not get it anywhere
else